وبالعوده الى موضوع القمه الاوروبيه
الاوكرانيه التي تقام اليوم في كييف ينضم
الينا من العاصمه الاوكرانيه مفد فرونس 24
عبد القادر درماس عبد القادر صباح الخير
ما اهداف هذه القمه وما المتوقع منها
مرحبا نجيب لاول مره يعقد على اوروبيون
قمه في دوله تخوض حربا القمه الاوروبيه مع
اوكرانيا مع انها رمزيه الان لكنها تحمل
مجموعه من الاشارات والرسائل القويه كثيرا
وجدا رسائل لاوكرانيا شعبا وقياده ورسائل
ايضا لموسكو يريدوا الاوروبيون ان يجددون
دعمهم اللامنتهي ولا مشروط في حربها التي
تقارب عامها الاول ويريدون ايضا ارسال
رساله الى موسكو مفادها ان الاوروبيون
الاوروبيون غير منقسمون مثل ما اشيع مؤخرا
حول حول الامداد وشكل الامدادات ومبلغ
الامدادات التي يريد الاوروبيون ان يقدمها
عفوا لاوكرانيا هذه الاشاعات صاحبه مؤخرا
قرارات برلين و واشنطن المتردده في ارسال
دبابات الى هذه هذه القمه ستعرف انزالا
ومشاركه بدايه من رئيسه المفوضيه
ذها الى رئيس المجلس وبعدها مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه الذي اكد ليله امس ان اوروبا
قدمت اكثر من 60 مليار دولار دعما عسكريا
وماديا لاوكرانيا وانها سوف تقرر مزيدا من
الدعم يتجاوز هذه المره الخامسه وعشرين
مليار دولار ليله امس وفي لقاء جمع
اورسولاف بالرئيس الاوكراني
انضمام بلده الى التكتل الاوروبي وقال انه
بانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي الشاب
الاوكراني سوف تزيد عزيمته وصموده في
محاربه في محاربه روسيا على كل هذه القمه
الى حد الان تبقى رمزيه لانها لن تحمل
الكثير عبد القادر ربما السؤال الذي يطرحه
الاوكرانيون هل يمكن لهذه القمه ان تغير
معادله الحرب في اوكرانيا
معادله الحرب من الصعب جدا الاوكرانيون
الاوكرانيون عفوا اليوم ينتظرون ان تقرر
او يقرر الاتحاد الاوروبي تسريع اجراءات
انضمامهم الى الى الى هذا الهيكل او
النادي الاوروبي لكن هذا صعب جدا هذه
القمه مثل ما قلت سوف اكرر هي قمه رمزيه
فقط لان الاوروبيون وضعوا امام اوكرانيا
مجموعه من الشروط لابد من اصلاح عميق
لمجموعه من القطاعات لابد من محاربه
الفساد
تحدث على رغبه بلاده في تسريع عمليه ضم
اوكرانيا للاتحاد الاوروبي مثل ما تطالب
السويد وجورجيا ومولدافيا وقال ان بلاده
مؤخرا قامت بعمليه كبيره لمكارحه لمحاربه
الفساد تم خلالها دعم منزل وزير الدفاع
السابق وزير الداخليه السابق ومجموعه من
رجال الاعمال لكن هذا ليس كافيا بالنسبه
للاتحاد الاوروبي الان الرئيس الفرنسي
قالها عده مرات انه لابد من عقود حتى تنضم
اوكرانيا لكن هذه القمه اريد لها في في
بعد مرور عام على هذه الحرب ان ترسل
مجموعه من الرسائل الى روسيا يريد ان يقرر
الاوروبيون اليوم مجموعه من العقوبات على
موسكو سوف يتم الاعلان عليها هنا شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه التفاصيل عبد القادر